hey guys so I'm so excited about today's
tech Tuesday because I've actually had
this fun little project in my possession
for a while and I haven't had a chance
to do my official review and unboxing
yet so I'm gonna do it now meet little
bits the little bits has tons of little
mini electronic circuit boards and
modules and little parts that you can
connect together to create amazing
electronic projects what's so cool about
this is you can do so many things I mean
right here on the box it says over 5
million circuit combinations and in this
box this is the deluxe kit this has 15
projects in this box
there's hundreds of projects online
before I even started shooting this
video I was like well I'm gonna just
look around and see what other people
have been making it's overwhelming and
they're so easy to do all you have to do
is stick them together they're made of
magnets ah let's open this thing up get
this got a knife I got a little demo
table here it's almost like I'm a
professional hmm okay let's open this up
welcome to little bits also in this bag
I haven't actually opened this one up
but this is to allow you to connect to
the cloud so using if-then that you can
connect your projects to your iPhone
through the internet and you can
actually do things and control things
and I'm so overwhelmed let's let's start
here first necked battery and cable to
module turn it on
pink modules affect modules after them
green modules do something let's go this
is great look at all these things this
is cool and their design is awesome like
everything just looks really slick so
I'm gonna make something here it started
with these but don't let us hold you
back every module fits with every other
module feel free to experiment I'm gonna
experiment and I'm gonna get really wild
and crazy and Otto why are there so many
things that we can do alright I want to
start out simple just to give you guys a
demo of how this works
all right first steps first we're gonna
connect our battery okay
connected battery to the power dimmer
connect you tada okay so here we go
let's just move some of this stuff out
of the way
here's the moment we've all been waiting
for what turn our dimmer up oh I have
done something I feel really
accomplished
alright let's disconnect our wire what's
this a botton up wrong way
holy moly I'm a genius
this is so awesome I want to make
something else
we are done now with the buzzer okay
there it is it's spinning this is my w74
it's my fork connect you to oh you're
you're just some pretty colors some
lights oh that's great dimmer I'm in
control hot louder's and it's look at
everything that I've got going on
there's so much stuff going on I'm
losing my mind I made this this is so
fun okay Shh silence yourself children
don't cut yourself hopefully going to
the hospital how cool
turn it on Upton inverter so if I push
the button it turns off it's like magic
you know so if this is something that
you guys might be into little bits is
actually giving you guys $20 off any $80
order if you're a first-time customer
which I think some of you maybe all you
have to do is use I just seen a checkout
and you get the nose
let me know what you guys think if you
see any cool projects that you think I
should try to build in a future whozit
video let me know because there are
endless possibilities I hope you guys
enjoyed this as much as I do I'm gonna
have so much fun building all kinds of
fun little projects so don't you guys
think I should build and I'm gonna I'm
gonna go build some stuff see you later
I am I am covered in circuits just the
way I like it